George Gilder you have a new book called
microcosm what is a microcopy
both plank Max Planck who invented
quantum theory said it was very
difficult for people to accept quantum
theory because it entailed movement from
the macrocosm where we ordinary live
ordinarily lived which we sense with our
senses into the microcosm of quantum
physics which is an invisible domain and
which operates according to law is
completely alien to those that govern
the things we see and feel and touch and
it's that move from macrocosm Newtonian
physics which behaves according to the
human senses the way billiard balls and
all those other analogies that are used
to depict conventional Newtonian physics
to quantum theory where you don't have
particles and substances in the sense
that you do in the know Tony in world
where in in the microcosm everything is
invisible and governed by quantum laws
which are very mysterious and contrary
to our usual beliefs and expectations
and it's quantum theory that governs the
microchip and it quantum theory that
explains the expectedness of
microelectronic technology are you have
you ever been afraid in this process of
writing this book that people like me
won't understand it no I mean I I
devoted it's really seven years to the
vision to writing this book and the
focus of those seven years was to make
anyone understand it and and I think I
probably did I mean I find that people I
know with no scientific background at
all are capable of understanding and
enjoying the book in it as a matter of
fact gaining a new appreciation for the
technologies that mystifies and
but also greatly dominate our lives and
so I think it gives a glimpse into the
microcosm and by understanding that it's
a completely different domain from the
macrocosm of our usual lives you can
understand it better I mean it's the
effort to try to treat it as if it's
just another mechanical technology as if
it's just another machine such as
another form of loom or or pick in place
robot it is a radically new technology
governed by completely different rules
why did you write this why did you spend
seven years writing this because I think
it's the most important thing that's
happening in the world today the
microchip is the most important
phenomenon in the world today and in the
next decade all the leading analysts
believe that we will move to a billion
transistors on a single sliver of
silicon the size of your thumbnail today
that means the equivalent of 20 Cray to
supercomputers what's all right to
Superman
it's the top of the line and computers
it costs 20 Billy 20 million dollars
apiece between 15 and 20 million dollars
apiece and you'll be able to put 20
Krays to supercomputer central
processing units on a sliver of silicon
the size of your thumb where it will
cost about a hundred bucks to produce
probably under a hundred bucks what
we're talking about is somewhere near a
ten thousandfold increase in the cost
effectiveness of computing in the next
decade or so this is the most important
thing that's happening in the world
today there's nothing that touches it
not Russia China third world debt all of
this is dwarfed in significance by this
infinitesimal microchip that becomes
exponentially more powerful every year
and as a matter of fact what happens in
China and this Soviet Union is largely
governed by their increasing intuition
that the way
and Asia possessing the microchip
capitalism possessing the microchip has
the secret to radically new technologies
of every description who controls
whether or not your theory will be in
actuality successful or what the word is
it will come to pass
well it's freedom I mean to the extent
that individuals are allowed to pursue
this technology to its potential it will
be achieved and because the technology
itself gives much greater power to
individuals against the authority of big
bureaucracies and governments I think it
is virtually inevitable that this
potential will be fulfilled it might not
if we retreat from the microcosm and
repress the technology in the United
States it'll probably be achieved in
Taiwan or some other nation but it will
be will be achieved and that's why it's
so critical that we cherish and develop
our tremendous resources in micro
electronics rather than disparage them
as we are today through some
short-sighted government policies I
believe it's a way of trying to
understand how you came to all this
where'd you write the book where did you
physically write the book mostly in my
basement and and and in my parents in a
office I have in my parents house down
the road I'd moved to different places
to write it I've written it in all sorts
of different places it was a portable
computer that I could carry from one
place to another a zine a super sport
that I could use almost everywhere I
wanted is it cheering here Massachusetts
Sheringham that's Joseph where is that
that's in the western part of
Massachusetts in the Berkshire Hills I'm
going to go through some of the
acknowledgments just as a way of trying
to understand how you put all this
together
who is Caltech professor Carver Mead
you say and here the role in the book
will be evident to any reader but also
important was the contribution of his
students and you name a whole bunch of
students well Carver Mead is one of the
Titans of micro electronics early he he
studied with Fineman who was the great
Caltech inventor of the latest version
of quantum theory and with delbruck who
is another Nobel Prize winner who
previously collaborated with Niels Bohr
who was one of the key inventors of
quantum theory and he proceeded on to
apply apply these theories to solid
state phenomena and when he did he
prophesied the kinds of prodigious
densities of on slivers of silicon that
currently are being achieved and at a
time when most people thought when you
got so many transistors so close
together on a chip the heat they would
generate so much heat that the chip
would melt and but or fry it was
generally believed that such densities
were not possible and he showed that as
you approach the mean free path the
smallest distance an electron can go
without colliding with the actual
cellular structure of the material
itself that everything gets cooler and
cheaper and faster and better as it gets
smaller and so you have an exponential
increase in capability as the density of
transistors on the chip gets greater and
greater as you get in first tens and
thousands and hundreds of thousands now
millions and later billions of
transistors on a chip it doesn't get
more difficult to make it doesn't each
function doesn't get more difficult to
make it doesn't fry it doesn't it gets
cooler and better and faster and cheaper
where did the students
the students taught me I mean I Carver
is an extraordinarily visit busy man he
consults with companies all over the
world he's right it was writing a new
book at the time and although he
lavished a lot of time on me he also
gave me access to all his students who
were willing to explain these
technologies laborious ly to me over the
years I had written a newsletter on the
industry for a year so I had a quite a
deep immersion in the industry but the
actual technology and physics at the
heart of it perplexed me until I did
plunge into this Caltech crucial of the
microcosm and so you'd go out to Cal
Tech in California where's it located
it's in Pasadena spend time yeah I spent
a lot of time there I'd go to go to the
Athenaeum which is one of the most
beautiful buildings in the country it's
their Faculty Club and and I'd stay
there and I'd go to Carver's courses and
talk to his students and interview
people and then I'd go to Silicon Valley
and interview people and companies many
of whom were fulfilling the technologies
that he was promoting and inventing
other things out of the acknowledgments
I want to ask you that I am deeply
indebted to Peter Sprague and Nick Kelly
for introducing me to the stirring and
crucial subject who are those two men Oh
Peter Sprague is chairman of national
semiconductor corporation he lives down
the road his wife was an old friend of
mine
he's an old friend of mine and my wife's
and and we're just have known each other
for years
and he is chairman of national
semiconductor and has it first intrigued
me with the technology I became
conscious of semiconductors because of
his role in the industry
Nick Kelley is CEO and was founder of a
company called Berkshire Corporation
which makes clean rum wipers apparel
materials disposables that get used in a
semiconductor cleanroom
and and in a clean room is 10,000 times
cleaner than for example an operating
room in a hospital 10000 times cleaner
so anything's dirty in a clean room so
what you have to do is analyze the
chemistry of anything you introduced
into the cleanroom very carefully and
exhaustively and so even paper products
which seem just disposable and simple do
have this high-tech dimension and neck
is an old friend of mine and he brought
me on the board of his company and we
went together to data quest conferences
on industry and I just learned more and
more and as time passed it became
evident to me that that if you could
fully comprehend the microchip its
physics its meaning its future you would
gain a deeper insight into the forces of
growth and change in the world economy
than by studying any other economic
subjects oh and although I'm an
economist I discovered that all the
materials I could study in economics
were less significant than the silicon I
could explore with Carver Mead Nick
Kelli Peters break and and scores of
entrepreneurs and engineers from micron
technology in Boise Idaho
they helped me tremendously to Cypress
Semiconductor and TJ Rodgers so just
lots of people contribute to writing
this book in the case of Nick Kelly at
the Berkshire corporation Berkshire is
where that's the area you live cheering
ham Massachusetts in the Berkshires know
these companies there right yeah even
though even you know all over the
country key technologies and key
companies find themselves involved
ultimately in the computer business in
some way or another
also to Ben rose and this is your debt
into Ben Rosen who's superb newsletter
taught me how to write about it
who has been Rosen and how to do what's
in his letter well Ben Rosen was an
analyst a financial technical analyst at
Morgan Stanley and he wrote the morgan
stanley electronics letter and it became
the most prestigious electronics letter
in the field and he spun it off by one
means or the other and started the Rosen
electronics letter which which I started
reading fanatically I mean it was just
so lucid and well-written it really gave
me a window into the microcosm that no
one else had given me so I read it just
fanatically what year did you start this
was back in late 70s early 80s and then
after I wrote wealth and poverty which
just had it had some references to
semiconductors you know they were the
key sort of example of company that
defied galbrace rules of the new
industrial state so I used it but I
didn't really pursue it closely and then
I went down to I just written an article
on micron technology for Forbes this
company in Idaho and I went to see Ben
Rose and to persuade him to give me the
newsletter free because I was tired of
stealing it and catching it and copying
it when I went from one company to
another and I was writing this book and
I thought I could persuade him to give
it to me free and he just read my piece
on micron and he said no no absolute
rule we can't give away free
subscriptions but you can write it if
you'd like
so I and at the time he was phasing out
of the newsletter business and selling
it to Esther Dyson another brilliant
writer focuses on software for the
personal computer business and and was
going into venture capital and his to of
this initial projects was Lotus
Corporation which makes the dominant
spreadsheet still and and the other
woman was
pack computer which is the fastest
growing business in history so he had a
magical touch as a venture capital it
was quite inspiring to me to see this
writer and analyst under venture capital
and immediately hit the two biggest
successes virtually in the industry long
journey I wrote it for about a year and
I wasn't very good I mean I was really a
big disappointment to the people who've
been reading been to read me but I
learned it I mean I really you know
every three weeks I had to do eight
pages of stuff on semiconductors and and
technical detailed analysis and I got
quite a lot of stuff right I mean I read
my mind newsletter and it it wasn't like
bands but it was you know I I did I was
beginning to figure out the industry
well at that point and it's and all of a
sudden it seemed to me that I was
capable of writing a major book on the
subject I want to come back to more on
the ecologist page you've written seven
books this is a book of all those books
public's most familiar with wealth and
poverty right what's the residual from
wealth when did you publish wealth and
poverty and today what do people most
say to you when they come up to you read
it or remember the controversy or their
supply-side economics you know they
associate it either with supply-side
economics or the idea that capitalism
consists chiefly of giving not taking
that the reason that the genius of
capitalism as it's a mode of discipline
giving are you comfortable that yeah I
think it's right and but a lot of this
idea which is the most radical idea in
wealth and poverty is still still
arouses a lot of resistance even among
conservatives who want to want really
cherish this idea that that
people are self-interested really
selfishness leads is by an invisible
hand to prosperous economy and I think
selfishness selfishness leads us by an
invisible hand to a socialist welfare
state because when people are really
selfish or greedy what they want is to
have the government assure them an
income that they haven't really earned
and so they're truly greedy petition to
the state to assure them their wealth
well well the real capitalist has to
serve other people he has to suppress
his own self-interest in order to serve
other people with goods and services
that they want rather than what he wants
and so but anyway that was the insight
of wealth and poverty which is still
most tenaciously resisted but I think is
probably the most important insight in
the book this is the new book by George
Gilder microcosm the quantum revolution
in economics and technology published by
Simon & Schuster what year was wealth
and poverty 1980-81
the books appeared in 80 and it
officially came out in January 81 in the
back of this book on a page there are
literally four lines that describe the
author you and I want to read it and
asking about it why just this is just
these four lines George Gilder lives in
tearing a Massachusetts with his wife
Nina Nina excuse me Nene and and poor
children
Louisa Mellie Mellie Richard and nan
Nina right and five computers right I
threw one of them way I have to say my
old Apple three finally gave up the
ghost and I carried it out by the road
and with great ceremony
I loved the junkman to carry it away
he is an associate of the Manhattan
Institute what's that that's terrific
Institute in Manhattan that supports Oh
books it
that identifies youthful book projects
and tends to support sub up and supports
the authors and actually supported me
recently financially support you find
not me that it has I still have my
health insurance through the Manhattan
Institute I was there for almost a year
a decade ago is a nonprofit organization
nonprofit organization and where does it
get its money it gets its money from
businesses and individuals who support
it projects Charles Murray's books were
largely supported by the Manhattan
Institute losing ground
Peter Huber is a extraordinarily
brilliant young writer who gave me
critical ideas for microcosm and he is
an associate of the Manhattan Institute
and this is the filing and the the
tearing ham Union Church it said you are
associative Manhattan sanitarium Union
Church and author of seven previous
books why did you mention the tearing
hand manager because because I think
it's an important there's a central part
of my life I add my it's where I go to
church where my family worships and I
think it's important for people to
understand that the values that sustain
high technology are not hostile to the
moral values that uphold the civilized
society and that that science and
religion are not hostile contending
forces any pursuit of truth and either
domain will tend to illuminate the other
and and they are you know that the
microchip is not a dehumanizing force or
materialist kind of determinate object
at what the domination is it
it's a Congregational Church the true
small town it's a small town of 200
people I've got one church and people of
various beliefs and attitudes but you
thought about this
before you put that in his book and that
was put in there for the reason yeah I
put it put it there because for that
reason I I think this one of the
important facets of this book is is to
unify the culture I think that there's
that there's a divided culture there's
the culture of Technology there's a
conservative culture of churches and
there there's a secular culture and
they're all battling and the idea is
that there's something innately hostile
to human values in modern technology and
I think the best human moral values are
indispensable to modern technology you
don't build a microchip through pursuing
hedonistic pleasures or dissipations
you're the microchip is a discipline
which Springs from the same kind of
family and and the religious values that
have upheld enterprise throughout the
history of the United States let me go
back end up capitalism for that matter
let me go back to the acknowledgments
here I could mention many friends and
family but two uncles put me put up with
the most i am deeply deeply indebted to
rodman Gilder and reece Alsop and
million lee are they yeah though they're
they're what four administration's -
mind body and spirit why did you why did
you mention Rodman Gilder and resource
on them they were there my father was
killed during the Second World War he
was an airline pilot and and actually
was roading riding a bucket of economics
at the time and his squadron was lost
airplane squadron of Flying Fortresses
and so my uncle's played a extraordinary
role in my life and some of his some of
my father's friends played an
extraordinary role
my way and rod and Rhys alsa rod Gilder
and Rhys also for the uncles who played
the father role more than any others in
my life and that from the beginning of
cultivated may their expose
extraordinary men and they where they
live
Rhys Allsop lives outside and Lloyd's
neck long I Long Island and he's a
doctor and poet and writer of children's
stories and an actor and he's at a
diverse life and Rodman Gilder lives in
Scarsdale New York where he's a
psychiatrist who is interested in theory
of the mind and also has a very broad
scope of fascination with the whole
range of intellectual pursuits and so so
as Malley and you know they've just been
very close to me and helped me with a
lot of the controversies in this book
always we're willing to discuss them and
by the way what are your kids think role
was there first there are a very
intrigued they're young
Louisa is 11 and Mellie is 8 and they're
the most and they're they're very
interested and we discuss it and I had a
discussion of quantum physics with
Louisa last night and she she thought it
sounded pretty fishy but but she wanted
me to explain just how the chip worked
and how one could build a chip and we
had quite an extensive conversation and
at the end of it I think she understood
it as well as the average reader of my
book would you tell her I told her that
the key to making a microchip is to view
it like a photograph it's like showing a
slide and when you show a slide
you magnify a picture well when you make
a microchip you get a big picture of
what you want on the microchip and you
reverse all lenses so you can
miniaturize it but it's the same
essential process based on use of light
to inscribe complex drawings that we
find in photography and photography
you've put in the slide and you magnify
it in photo lithography for writing
microchips you put in a big design of
the microchip and you miniaturize it but
it's the same kind of lens system that's
used and you can and this
miniaturization process is so powerful
that today you can put hundreds of
transistors not on the head of a pin but
on the point of a pin and it's it's a
it's fabulous technology that really in
a sense overcomes the usual constraints
of time and space when you can put
hundreds of transistors on the point of
a pen and switch them in trillions of
seconds you've overcome both the usual
constraints of both time and space and
it is it is a technology that truly
overthrows matter in the usual sense
where things get more powerful as they
grow bigger in the microcosm things grow
more powerful as they get smaller it's a
radically different kind of process what
happened as you described this to your
daughter what did you what did you see
happening in her eyes I saw her but get
the picture of a slide you can
understand that she could get the idea
that uh that a photograph was a
complicated chemical product and and
then there was a certain resistance to
the idea that you could make this
photograph switch and work and in this
exciting way I just come from Forbes
magazine that gave a party launching my
book
and Malcolm Forbes has on the wall this
fantastic little pinball machine which
is a work of art I mean it's a beautiful
clever little machine that sends balls
going through little gates and jumping
back and forth and all sorts in an
amazing choreography that works
perfectly every time I mean the it all
the balls are collected at the right
place and they're sent down shoots at
the right time and they whirled down
spirals and a glittering rushed at just
the perfect moment and the whole thing
is a logical system it's like a chip and
Louisa was ready to recognize that you
could put a you know a million
transistors are enough transistors on a
sliver of sand by this photographic
process to depict the this machine but
you couldn't understand how you could
make the machine actually work and there
I had to explain how gravity in that
pinball machine on the wall is replaced
by voltage on the microchip and voltage
is a direct analog of gravity where you
have just as the ball goes from the high
point to the low point the electron goes
from the high point to the low point and
in an electronic device from positive
from negative to positive as it happens
we're talking with George Gilder this is
what the book looks like you're on the
tour yeah I'm on tour what do you think
of tours you you like this I like
talking about what you've written yeah
this is this is a good it's a good and
unique conversation I've never had a
conversation like this about my book but
any of my books before it's quite an
interesting way to proceed they're going
through the acknowledgments with is uh
does really what work in a way
and gets an original perspective on I
was quite interested
do you enjoy this part of what you're
doing I mean not just this interview but
do you enjoy going around and doing
radio call-in shows and all that stuff
sometimes I mean it's it it's very
tiring I mean I didn't sleep last night
I was so keyed up after my last program
in New York I went to the Metroliner and
and had a bed in the Metroliner but I
just tossed and turned all the way down
to Washington so I'm so so it's
exhausting but very exciting when
something works I mean when you really
feel you're communicating successfully
that is exciting and gratifying just as
it partakes of the gratification of of
writing itself when when it's not
working it becomes laborious and and
frustrating so it's just like anything
else but it it I think
writers are very apt to disparage the
tour they all got to do the tour and
they're very apt to disparage it and but
it has more gratifications than they
usually acknowledge I think and
including the you know just the
excitement of it I mean it is just
exciting you never know what's gonna
happen do you ever write in a book like
this tucked away buried in the middle of
chapters something that you just wonder
if anybody's ever going to discover I
mean where you going so but I've got
this theory I'm just going to throw this
in a couple days usin and see if anybody
ever figures it out I don't think so I
mean what what usually happens in a book
like this is that after you write it the
ideas emerge more clearly and you
actually wish you could rewrite some
party yeah and you wish you could go
back and do it again and and that
happens with every book you write and
it's and it's more likely to happen that
you did something less well and you'd
expect you have as usual dedicated this
book
and this page there's one named Richard
vigilante who is it
he was article attic editor at National
Review magazine and who has been
interested in my work for 10 years or so
and who took a special interest in this
book and during a period when I was
having great trouble getting this huge
mass of material and order and giving it
a coherent logic he came up and helped
me do it page by page chapter by chapter
logical point by logical point and
without him it would have been enormous
ly difficult to get this book in the
format it is and and it wouldn't have
been as good I mean he really decisively
improved the book I mean I've editors
are very important to me I mean I don't
think that book was as I wrote at least
three times as much stuff as this so I
had to distill a material down to this
size and I'd been told in general how to
do it by Bob Asahina of Simon & Schuster
who was the original editor for this
project and carried it all the way
through and he told me what to do but
doing it and that was vital to it but
doing it was hard and I couldn't have
done it without Richard and he he came
up tutoring him where I live and and
worked with me on it for probably a
month altogether or more and helped me
get the book done and incoherent and
functioning and I think it does function
now it really does does have a coherence
from beginning to end that that he
really helped in part to it there's
another couple of names that jump out of
the page David and Peggy Rockefeller
once again offered their generous
hospitality for long extensive
uninterrupted writing and editing and
gave me a vivid sense of the presence of
my father in my life and in there
who's David and Peggy Rockefeller David
David and Peggy are you know where my
father and mothers virtually best
friends when I do David Rockefeller and
he and my father he roomed with my
father in college and when my father
died in the war David took a very
special interest in me for and Peggy for
years and I spent a lot of summers with
their children and and he imparted to me
this sense of the importance of what my
father had been doing and his sacrifice
in the war and the meaning of it and the
possibilities for my life and and he
really did did contribute very
importantly a couple of other things and
you just can't believe how much how
there's not enough time to get to all of
us that's why probably some people want
to buy this book George Gilder author
the best-selling wealth and poverty
writes regularly for The Wall Street
Journal the National Review the American
Spectator Forge another publication he
has been a fellow of the Kennedy School
of Government at Harvard a speechwriter
for Nelson Rockefeller and Ronald Reagan
and semiconductors editor of release 1.0
1.0 Arielle you stood for the Rosen
electronics letter release 1.0 as Esther
Dyson took it over and converted it into
into her letter when did you write
speeches from Ronald Reagan I never did
write to be just for Ronald Reagan
that's I have written a speech for
Ronald Reagan I've consulted with speech
writers for Ronald Reagan a great deal
but that's a mistake that Simon Shuster
I hope will correct and the next
decision my cousin Joshua Gilder was
Ronald Reagan's leading speechwriter and
there's some confusion here of me with
him but he was the speech writer and I I
did write a draft of Reagan's acceptance
speech and did you know but I was not a
ever a real speechwriter for Reagan the
reason I asked that was for that very
reason I also noticed that taking time
off from vile
chores his presidential speechwriter
Joshua Gillard did heroic work as the
first reader to emerge from the swamps
of a much longer and less intelligible
version of this manuscript and you say
he's your cousin right wrote speeches
from Ronald Reagan that's right terrific
speeches he wrote the Moscow you aren't
allowed to say who wrote speeches but he
he wrote President Reagan's speech at
Moscow State University which I think
was the high point of the Reagan
administration you took the words right
out of my mouth I saw this in here yeah
I've got my little exercise yeah I
wondered you use this excerpt at the
beginning one of the chapters let me
close the book James and I'm gonna read
this so you can I want to ask you why
you used in the new economy this is
President Ronald Reagan at Moscow State
University when was that at the end of
88 yeah it was toward the end of his
ministry no November what it don't I
have a date there you're not yeah I
think you November 88 maybe you know
that doesn't sound right I'm not sure
just when it was in the new economy
human invention increasingly makes
physical resources obsolete even as we
explore the most advanced reaches of
science we're returning to the age-old
wisdom of our culture and the beginning
was the spirit and it was from this
spirit that the material abundance of
creation issued forth your cousin wrote
it well he wrote it for Reagan and
Reagan said it and Reagan like saying
those things I mean he's bread Ronald
Reagan still saying these things today
without my cousin he just recently gave
the speech which focused on that
principle he's that was a theme of his
administration but but Josh did right
though right that particular speech the
new American challenges chapter 24 and
this heads up actually a partner book
the quantum economy right why did you
use that quote and what's the essence of
that chapter
well that quote really applies to the
whole last section of the book and it
probably applies to the last chapter
more than any other chapter as the as
you may see the
votes are worse but I you know it
happens that in the course of publishing
the book the quotes were supposed to be
in in this dividers dividers between the
five parts of the book and instead
they're put in the first chapter of each
part and that was just that was supposed
to be there rather than in the next page
but once this happened it was hard to
change at the last moment so I didn't
what you're saying is that that quote
was supposed to be on this page just a
page that separates the parts then you
turn the page and write okay and back to
the original question on this the new
American challenge what is the new
American job no the new American
challenge is the American challenge to
the world that recapitulates in a
different form the first American
challenge which Servan Shriver the great
french editor identified in late 60s as
the American military industrial complex
and that they believed at the time that
the new technologies necessarily
concentrated power and required huge
industrial corporations to pursue and
and Servan Shriver believed that the
American challenge to Europe and to the
world economy was this alliance between
the Pentagon and us high technology
companies like IBM and AT&T and and the
defense contractors that were
spearheading technology it was very like
the theory that we currently offer for
Japan that somehow there's a new
Japanese challenge that consists of
gigantic companies and in alliance with
the state and the thesis of this book is
that micro electronics the law of the
microcosm breaks up the
accumulations of power inevitably
because you can the power of the chip
grows by the square of the number of
transistors you can put on the chip but
the communications power just grows very
slowly it's like the number of leads you
can have from the chip to the macrocosm
are very limited they're limited by the
circumference of the chip and sometimes
you can put some leads under the chip
but it's very limited the number of
leads you can use to connect outside the
chip but the processing power that on
the chip grows hugely and so so what
happens here it's like the human being
we can do tremendous amount of
processing in this head that it all just
comes out of this one little bottleneck
the lower nose and you know and this
this technology resembles the mind and
it's a information technology and it
resembles the mind in that regard and
what the mind does is make us unique
individuals and and separate in some
sense and this law of the microcosm
we're off the chip and the macrocosm
complexity grows by the square of the
number of nodes or switches or
interactions or or entities that have to
be controlled complexity grows by the
square of the number of nodes outside
the chip but on the chip efficiency
grows about by the square of the number
of transistors and so so all big
organizations tend to break down because
they when that when you attempt to
control them from the top because they
grow impossibly complex
but meanwhile on the chip efficiency is
growing more and more as you concentrate
exponentially faster than the number of
of leads from the chip so so what you've
got this this tremendous centrifugal
force at the heart of technology it's
really explosive when you get an
exponential growth in the power of
processing in just an arithmetic growth
and the communications capabilities and
that's that's what that's why the works
that's why in 1977 nearly a hundred
percent of all the processing power in
the world was in giant mainframes and
today less than 1% of all processing
power in the world is in giant
mainframes it's a it's a radical
centrifugal force all the top-down
systems with gigantic computer power
concentrated in the center and dumb
terminals attached to it was our a
giving way to what are called peer
networks of intelligent terminals where
the intelligence and the processing
power is on the desktop rather than in
some data processing center far away and
that affects television and broadcasting
the factory automation
telecommunications everywhere the
intelligence is moving away from
centralized controlling concentrations
to the desktop to the individual let me
ask you about that list in Louisa's 11
or 8 your daughter she's 11 she's alive
Meli's 8 and she's she's coming along to
on this note them okay let's take those
two daughters of yours and let's get
them up to our age I'm not sure how old
you are I'm close to 48 contemporaries
when when they get to be our age what
does all this mean is there a way that
you can describe to a generalist out
there what this is gonna mean for our
lives when there are a well I think
the crux of it is that all the dreams of
despots people who think that by
controlling the whole system they'll be
able to create some wonderful utopian
world will be frustrated because what's
going to happen is individuals are going
to be endowed by increasing creative
power year after year after year at at a
steadily increasing pace so that there
will be just much more opportunities for
individual creativity the government at
all will a president be a mother I think
I think they'll be able to govern better
because this is one of the great
insights of the
Austrian economist that that the effect
of a government plan is to port all the
plans of all the individuals who are
closest to the problems and who can plan
most effectively and fulfill their plans
most affirmatively and so what you have
when you have a big government plan is
one of these big systems that becomes
overwhelmed by its own complexity
you know the complexity grows
exponentially up in the macrocosm and
all these macrocosmic planning schemes
break down because of the law of
complexity but this scheme and the
microchip increased steadily in power as
they are emancipated and that means the
world will work much better than it will
when you have all these complexity
crises breaking out all over in your
book you this is really off the subject
but I want to ask you about in your book
you write that it cost something like 80
cents a page No 80 cents a book is if
you talk about a book like this to make
it yeah something like that it's all it
cost to make a book about like that
Manufacturing surprised and a chip cost
about 80 cents to manufacture I mean
that's an ID and a floppy disk costs
about 80 cents and the actual medium of
a hard disk costs something in that
order I mean it's it's between 80 cents
and two
dollars is the general cost to
manufacture media where's the other
nineteen dollars and fifteen cents go
ideas it goes it goes to all the parts
of the economy that people tend to
disparage is somehow worthless services
or or information a coast to the writer
it goes who gets ten ten fifteen percent
of it it goes to editors it goes to
distributors goes to book store
retailers it goes goes to and truckers
and advertisers and all kinds of people
who participate in launching that
information product manufacturing is you
know in this product is less than 10
percent of the value how important is
this book to you is it's your most
important out of eight I think so yeah
I think it's it's it's probably the most
coherent and best of my eight books and
most original probably how many copies
did they print on the first printing I
do not know do you expect this book to
be one of those it takes off from it
it's a best-seller less than I think
it's it it is a really original book it
really is different from any book out
there so so I think it'll take a while
for people to discover it I think it's
gonna be it's gonna be a book that'll
build and I hope that builds a long time
and builds well but but I'd it's it's
not sort of something that can is
instantly convertible into a new program
as wealth and poverty was I mean wealth
and poverty was supply-side theory and
it and and Reagan was about to enact
supply-side programs so if you
understood the theory you could
understand the program better and and so
it was it had a sort of spontaneous
combustion there that and this this is
really for people want to understand
their world and then how it's going to
change in the neck
20 years more radically than it has
changed in the last 20 years I think
this is an accelerating movement rather
than a maturing industry as some people
believe I think we're just at the
beginning because the power of the
technology is beginning to reach
capabilities that that openin up more
the human beings like speech recognition
speech I talked a lot about speech
recognition in here the next frontier
when you can talk to your computers it
will open them up to you they'll become
more easy to use I don't know the first
thing about computers am I gonna be in
trouble if I don't learn according to me
I get the sense when I read this and I
better learn this you're gonna use them
all they're all around you and you're
gonna you're gonna be using them all
your life in various ways without
knowing it and that's that's what's
really going to happen to the computer
industry rather than being something
that computer freaks enjoy and pursue
and specialized ways you'll have a
proliferation of this intelligence
dispersed throughout the world and then
that that will mean that even though you
don't know any software programs or or
nor do you build microchips you will it
will be part of your world and it will
change your world in an important way
the overthrow of matter from the will
become an increasingly influential force
in your future there is a chapter in
here that it's a very parochial question
when I ask them called the death of
television right and another thing I
haven't asked you about is analog and
digital before we go into the death of
television let me ask you can you very
quickly and I I know this is probably
impossible can you define what analog
and digital are and what what's the
difference between the two of them well
they're they're really two ways of
representing information in an analog
system you actually reproduce an analogy
of the phenomenon that is being depicted
in other words if you have somebody uh
ters a sound you reproduce those sound
waves in voltages or currents so that
those sound waves are translated into it
into an electronic analogy you have
waves that resemble the waves that the
sound pressure waves that your utter
insist produce you CNN scope yeah you
see it on a scope as a sine waves but
you can't see it with your eyes no you
can't see it with your eyes digital
digital is converting these two numbers
and rather than conveying the sounds of
your voice by reproducing voltages and
currents that resemble the waves that
you utter you you take the amplitude of
each of these waves and convert it to a
number and and what's the better thing
for the future is it all gonna be
digital no it's not all gonna be digital
analog is very efficient for pattern
recognition our eyes for example operate
by an analog system and our eyes are
capable of more visual processing than
all the supercomputers in the world put
together our eyes are the incomparable
the most efficient of computer system
there is and if they're almost entirely
an analog process but digital has one
great virtue because numbers can be
reduced to a binary code of on-off
switches you can deal with these numbers
billions trillions of times without any
errors an analog builds up because it's
because it it copies the very pattern of
your speech or whatever it has in a
old-fashioned record it can have errors
as it wears out
while and in a digital compact disk
either the numbers are correct and you
can read the numbers or you can't and if
you can read the numbers the rendition
of the sound will be perfect television
that's the television and it's written
all over as a technology however
television is dead you all say say if TV
is dead HDTV the high-definition
television is still born all right we're
back to Louisa and and Melly what are
they going to be looking at them
computers
they'll be it'll be a digital computer
system that that they will they will be
watching it works like this won't exist
not exactly like this programs good
programs will be more valuable because a
good program will be very cheap to
transmit to all the people who want to
see it
so therefore the profit from that
program will go directly to the people
who originate it rather than most of
that profit going to the people who
distribute it who own the antennas or
whatever hard for a president then to
capture the attention the American
people at one time it'll be harder that
that it will be possibly harder unless
he has something important to say he
won't be he
I don't think broadcasting is gonna go
away but I think the power of the
technology which is more resembles the
telephone than broadcasting top down
system where a few broadcasters decide
what you see is so much more powerful
and attractive if you can dial up
whatever program in the world you want
to see any database any movie any
anything you want to see dial it up over
fiber-optic telephone lines it will make
it hard for broadcast of systems to
compete George Gilder unfortunately
we're out of time this is what this book
looks like microcosm the quantum
revolution economics and technology
and this is in your book stores
published by Simon & Schuster thank you
very much